promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans ProMix cité l'émission
qui vous parle de la place des femmes
dans le monde du travail aujourd'hui
focus sur la parité qui peut se révéler
gagnante pour une entreprise dit
autrement les sociétés est plus
exemplaires en matière de parité
surperforme c'est ce qui ressort d'une
étude du gestionnaire d'actif Blackrock
ainsi entre 2013 et 2022 les entreprises
les plus égalitaires ont obtenu un
rendement de 7,7 % contre 5,6 % pour
celles employant davantage d'hommes et
6,1 % pour celles employant davantage de
femmes donc vous le voyez c'est plus la
diversité qui compte que la prévalence
d'un sexe sur un autre à noté également
que la présence de femmes dans des des
postes de direction jouent sur la
performance avec notamment moins de
turnover au sein de l'entreprise enfin
la durée du congé maternité et lui aussi
un critère qui compte les sociétés qui
en proposent des plus longs génèent un
rendement supérieur de
1,07 %. voilà promic cité c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite sur public
Scéna promixité vous a été présenté par
NG acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle
elle